ja wir brauchen in Deutschland unbedingt
einen respektvollen Umgang miteinander
das Miteinander trotz inhaltlicher
Unterschiede ist leider zu kurz gekommen
wir haben verlernt über sachpunkte zu
streiten ohne beleidigen zu wirken
gerade Corona zeigt wie sich erfronten
verhärten zwischen geimpfte und
ungeimpfte wie Dinge missbraucht werden
stattdessen doch das Miteinander so
wichtig ist eine Krise zu bewältigen
miteinander zu reden die beste Lösung zu
finden muss unser Motto sein und deshalb
hat auch die Ampel jetzt beschlossen
dass die digitale Gewalt stärker in
Fokus gerückt wird denn häufig sind auch
die Netze in denen übergrifflichkeiten
stattfinden und unser Anspruch muss es
sein und die Ampel als eingeleitet das
wird trotz unterschiedlicher
inhaltlicher Positionierungen in der
Sache respektvoll miteinander umgehen
ohne Beleidigung zu werden
ja also ich finde das ich gleich mal
gleich ein finde das ein super
spannendes Thema weil ich komme aus dem
Social Media Bereich und da hat man das
ja tagtäglich dass die Leute diskutieren
ob man jetzt halt irgendwie gemobbt wird
oder ob man seine Meinung sagen darf
oder auch nicht und finde es ganz ganz
wichtig dass man das aus verschiedenen
Perspektiven betrachtet und weil das
Thema Mobbing bzw der Gegenseite
gegenseitige Respekt ist einfach sehr
sehr wichtig und finde ich dass man in
der Gesellschaft viel
öfter und häufiger wieder leben sollte
ja also der Umgang ist extrem wichtig
ich habe eben den Begriff zum ersten Mal
gehört ich finde den sehr spannend
vielleicht liegt es an mir dass ich den
erst jetzt höre digitale Gewalt finde
ich hervorragend um das zu bezeichnen
worum es in der Diskussion in der
öffentlichen wirklich geht habt ihr neu
geprägt in der Koalition Vereinbarung
digitale Gewalt oder haben sie das eben
erfunden wir hatten tatsächlich schon in
den letzten Fraktion in der letzten
Legislatur einen umfassenden Antrag zum
Bekämpfung
digitaler Gewalt weil es häufig ja die
übergrifflichkeiten sind die im Netz
stattfinden Twitter beispielsweise ist
reden dafür aber auch viele andere
sozialen Netzwerke und Plattformen
bieten dort die Möglichkeiten und häufig
trifft natürlich aber auch Frauen junge
Frauen ganz besonders junge Politiker
ganz besonders und ich wünsche mir ein
Land in dem tatsächlich auch mehr junge
Menschen in die Politik den Schultern
brauchen wir Klarnamen Pflicht im
Internet weil das ist das ist ja das
Hauptproblem 99,9% gefühlt würden ja den
ganzen
scheiß gar nicht schreiben und Leute
Moppen wenn Sie das mit Klarna machen
müssen wäre das nicht einfach die
logische Konsequenz man muss mit
Klarnamen auf der Straße trauen sich die
Leute auch nicht die Leute an zu spucken
an zu schreien anzuschubsen wobei auch
das zunehmend der Fall wird aber gerade
durch Corona ist das mittlerweile schon
der Fall ist es gibt keiner da wo jetzt
tatsächlich auch gesetzliche Stellen ist
das möglich ich denke die Schwelle der
übergrifflichkeit wird deutlich gesenkt
wenn man sich ja deutlich auch als
Person dazu outen muss dass man so
solches Verhalten zeigt und dazu
tatsächlich sind häufig Accounts die
solche brutalen Beschimpfungen von sich
geben die tatsächlich keiner expliziten
Personen die keine Freunde haben und
auch keine Bilder hochladen und das ist
natürlich schon bedenklich dennoch ist
es ein Stück weit auch dass man abwägen
muss Datenschutz persönlichkeitsthematik
wie man das aneinander stellt eine
andere rechtliche Grundlage wenn zum
Beispiel Boris Palmer werden morgen
übrigens genau auch darüber bei Bild
berichten über Hass im Netz und wo es
Palma der grünen Politiker
Oberbürgermeister von Tübingen den habe
ich heute um Statement gebeten und er
hat mir dann geschrieben dass er schon
über 100 Fälle angezeigt hat
strafrechtlich also er hat digitale
Gewalt über 100 Mal angezeigt
strafrechtlich nicht ein einziges Mal
wurde ein Verfahren eröffnet und er hat
gesagt die gesetzliche Grundlage muss
dringend nachgeschärft werden was wird
die FDP da machen genau das ist ja Teil
auch das Koalitionsvertrages den wir
verankert haben die auf lückenlose
Umsetzung der istanbul-konvention und
die istanbul-konvention ist in einem
Jahr entstanden wo das Thema digital
Netz ja noch gar nicht vorhanden war und
deshalb ist es notwendig neben der
eigentlich die istanbul-konvention und
fast eigentlich den Kampf gegen
häusliche Gewalt gegenüber Frauen Männer
aber auch Kinder und Jugendliche was
lustig ist dass es in Istanbul gerade
passiert weil die Erfahrung bildlich das
alles machen nicht also es gibt einige
Länder die auch aus dem staatenvertrag
es kann jetzt weiter es werden irgendwas
gehört da unbedingt die digitale Gewalt
mit dazu und das muss man erstmal die
Weichen stellen es gibt auch dass die
Justiz die die Polizei die
Rechtsprechung auch entsprechend
geschult werden muss welche
Möglichkeiten existieren denn auch ein
Stück weit sensibilisiert werden muss
denn es ist ein wahrlich ein Problem und
gerade junge Menschen die im sozial im
Netz tätig sind
angesprochen hast sollten wir die Namen
wirklich dann hinter den Accounts legen
ich denke jeder Account hinter jedem
Account steckt eine Person also ein
Mensch ja heißt es ist ganz wichtig dass
gerade auch Creator influencer wie auch
immer man sie nennen möchte einfach als
Vorbild fungieren und da viel viel mehr
ansetzen und sie sich zum Beispiel auch
nicht untereinander mobben oder wie auch
immer sondern einfach zeigen dass man
das diese Umgänge auch im Netz leben
kann ja also es geht nicht darum immer
besser und anders als wahrscheinlich
schon auch die Medien anfangen also zum
Beispiel Frau Bauer sie war ja gerade
erst betroffen finde ich bei TV Total
ich fand es ehrlich gesagt nicht lustig
gerade aktuell ein bisschen auch um das
Ziel hinausgeschossen aber bei den
Lockdown machen was da richtig richtig
ausgeschlossen die Frage ist die Frage
ist ja ganz klar jetzt sie wohnen ja bei
TV Total da hat man ja die sexieste
Biene der FDP gesucht das waren absolut
Unding für mich aber muss man da nicht
haben sie sich da zum Beispiel beschwert
und direkt gesagt also hier fehlt mir
der Respekt auf mir gegenüber als
Politikerin sollte man da nicht auch
schon einsetzen vielleicht ja was ich da
spannend gefunden habe das nicht nur ich
mich beschwert habe weil das ist immer
schwierig wenn man als Betroffener sich
beschwert sondern dass sich eine
unglaubliche Solidarität im Netz
gebildet hat unterschiedliche Menschen
haben es gesagt und so geht es nicht wir
sind im 21 Jahrhundert und ist auch mein
Statement das sind im 21 Jahrhundert
eine Frau die Politik machen möchte die
unser Land gestalten möchte darauf
reduziert dass sie gut aussieht ist das
die Eigenschaft die wir thematisieren
wollen passiert es denn den Männern auch
oder wollen wir ein Land in dem der
Respekt Zelt indem wir wirklich
Veränderungen auf dem Weg bringen wollen
indem wir auch hart streiten das Sache
aber trotzdem immer respektvoll
miteinander umgehen und es wünsche ich
mir und das hat mir die Ampel gezeigt
allein die ganzen
Koalitionsverhandlungen auch das
sondierungspapier wie wenig danach außen
geht rum ist aber wie immer das
zusammengearbeitet hat und ich kann
sagen ich war selber in der
Arbeitsgruppe Klima Energie und
Transformationen natürlich würde hart
gerungen über die Themen es sind auch
keine leichten Themen gerade auch wenn
man sagt was das für Erwartungen oder
was das auch für möglicherweise für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger bedeutet aber
hart zu streiten und deshalb dennoch
respektvoll miteinander umzugehen finde
ich schon notwendig und mir war es
unglaublich wichtig dass es da ja eine
Welle ausgeht wirklich losgetreten habe
dass viele Menschen sich die Frage
stellt haben so geht's nicht ich immer
noch Zuschriften aber ich habe eben auch
in dieser Zeit Zuschriften erhalten die
mehr als unter der Gürtellinie waren wo
ich schon sagen muss wo auch diejenigen
die man auch stückweit mit denen ich ja
meinen Social Media Kanal gezeigt habe
auch mal ein bisschen mitlesen konnten
wo ich schon gesagt das muss sich
verändern